dr ramani amúgy ő az egyik szaktekintény
most így a világon igen ő a kaliforniai
egyetemnek az egyik professzora kutató
professzor és amúgy egy nagyon híres
podcaster is és ő elég határozottan
mondta azt hogy egy nárcisztikus személy
egy nárcisztikus jellem nem fog változni
és ez ez ez egy borzasztó amikor én
erről hallottam először ez egy
pokoljárással volt egyenértékű nekem
mert a keresztény nevelésem nem engedte
ezt a a a gondolatot magamhoz közel mert
a keresztény nevelés azt mondja hogy
hányszor kell megbocsátani valakinek
70zer hétszer
ki tehát hogy hogy ki az aki bűntelen
hát én sem azt dobja rá az első követ
aki bűntelen úgyhogy valahogy úgy voltam
vele hogy hogy én én nem télhetem meg az
embert ki tudja hogy fog-e változni vagy
nem fog változni ramani valójában azt
mondta hogy statisztikailag ő nem látott
egyszer se olyan releváns változást amit
tényleg tényleg számítana